the top stories in the sky world news a
quarter patrol today decide whether to
order the South African governments to
arrest Sudan's President Omar al-bashir
and hand them over to the International
Criminal Court in The Hague he's in
Johannesburg for an African Union summit
the Libyan government says the Algerian
militant Moktar belmoktar thinking of
the US air strike in salty water the
attack on an hour during gas plant in
2013 when 37 of hostages were killed
thousands of Syrian refugees have fled
across the Turkish border as Kurdish
forces prepare for a major clash with is
or more now on our top story that a
court in South Africa has ordered the
authorities not to allow Sudan's
President to leave the country pending a
decision on whether to arrest him for
war crimes earlier we spoke to two
lezzie lezzies similarly in Johannesburg
who's a senior political correspondent
for the TV news channel en-ca it's
really a big deal for South Africa if
you think about the fact that in 2009
there was a point where South African
President Jacob Zuma was interviewed on
international news networks and spoke
about you know the obligation that South
Africa has to arrest Omar al-bashir if
he were to set foot on South African
soil and President Jacob Zuma day
unequivocal saying that because we are
signatories of the International
Criminal Court South Africa would be
obliged to not stand in the way of Omar
al-bashir being arrested when it does
come here and I remember Omar al-bashir
was supposed to travel to the Bob way
for the commercial summit in that
particular year there was that reminder
to him that he cannot at any point enter
south african air space or even land in
South Africa because South Africa was
under obligation to arrest him so for
things to turn around within a period of
six years to a point where South Africa
is willing to open up the gates for him
is really a big deal and he is being
challenged in the courts here in South
Africa and there's an interim order that
he cannot leave South Africa until you
know the matter has been fully argued
before the courts and a final judgment
reached one imagines that for Omar
al-bashir to you know be so bold as to
come to South Africa there needs to have
been some assurances from the South
African government but also from the
African Union because you know we've
been asking these questions about
whether Omar al-bashir will be coming
to South Africa for a good four weeks
from officials from our department of
international relations and cooperation
and the answer the standard answer that
I've been getting initially was and you
know Omar al-bashir knows as well as the
South African government does what is at
stake here and the initial expectation
was that he would not be coming but
later on the narrative started to change
and we started hearing all inquiries
about whether he will be attending or
not should be directed to the African
Union and whose invitation Omar
al-bashir is attending the summit here
and it went from there to now the
African National Congress talking about
the International Criminal Court having
outlived its usefulness for the purpose
for which it was actually established so
you are seeing a shifting of the
position and the concern in South Africa
is whether President Jacob Zuma will
comply with a court order if indeed the
order is made final that Omar al-bashir
should not leave